so let me ask you this question
um pick somebody that's a popular figure
either in Hollywood or you know somebody
that we would know that you're keen on
like do you have a crush on a female
actress or a I don't know a musician or
anything
uh like what's hot to you
a lot a lot of things um
I don't know give me an example of a
woman
Zendaya
Zen die okay I gotta look that up
because I don't know that so I'm gonna
pull it up over here hold in a second is
that zetty yeah no it's z-e-n-t-a-y-a
-y-a Zendaya American actress okay
uh
it's kind of a mulatto chick she looks
like she's mixed
yeah uh okay so who is this I've never
heard her before uh Emmy golden gold
name one of most influential people in
the world she's 26 years old
okay yeah she's attractive uh what Zen
what are these one name people it's like
Prince
uh what is she known for Donna received
accolades Primetime actress singer
Hollywood okay
all right so I don't know who this is
yeah she's like
this chick's hot right like you would be
happy with a woman like this if she said
yo Bob I dig your Vibe yeah okay
so that's kind of yeah okay so why are
we going out with average 140 pound
women that are 10 years older than you
then
you just try to get a start somewhere
because I'm I'm I'm
just I'm a bit desperate desperate okay
so you're lowering your standards
I mean to me she wasn't like
unattractive but I've definitely like
well 140 pounds 5 foot 933 does not look
like Zendaya
she looks younger than her age
she looked like she was in her 20s she
looked at but this but this Zendaya
chicks fit right like she's a yes
you know she's your typical uh how tall
is she she looks pretty small but I'm
not I'm not like I know I'm I'm just an
average I'm not gonna get and die anyone
like that well you're not going to get
her with that attitude and the fact that
you're too light and that you're not
captive and you got the anxiety like
you'll never get her with that stage in
your life but
I mean I will tell you flat out I mean
it's entirely plausible that
this kind of check would be the kind of
Gala you know you could have in your
life and I'm not saying that to fluffy
up or to lie to you or say that you know
this is a light at the end of the tunnel
but dude like you have so much growth
that's
you know within you you got so much
potential you've you've just got to deal
with all the issues that are holding you
back and again I would never recommend
to any guy to deal with these issues to
get the girls like dealing with these
issues to get girls I understand will
get them but it should be for yourself
first it should be you know so that
you've got options in your life so you
can have a better career so that you can
make more money so that you can live
longer in a healthier body you know do
all these things but it's like
you know the byproduct will be having
more opportunities and more options with
women you understand what I'm saying
here right yeah I do
anyway
um like you know this chick she's a good
looking girl
um definitely plausible you know it's
definitely plausible
um but you have no no chance right now
with where you're at right now so I want
you I want you to get your ass in the
gym and put on some weight I want you to
aim for 150 560 pounds to get there
train with your friend
um read on how to how to bulk up there's
lots of videos out on the internet that
show you how to do it you can buy
programs that will uh walk you through
it if you need more guidance make sure
you feed your body make sure you're
taking in sufficient protein uh don't be
afraid of red meat red meat is great for
you it's one of the best foods that you
can possibly consume definitely have
chicken have fish you know have the
other uh protein sources
um make sure you're throwing some greens
in your body I mean if you want to
really get fully geeky on
um like biohacking and optimizing your
health about a month and a half ago
maybe within the last two months I did a
podcast on the topic breaking down
everything that I do uh blood work you
know origin of your genome what to eat
what you might have inflammatory
responses to and entailing yourself to
that like
I can like like Bob I'm not saying this
to be mean to you but I'm a lot older
than you and I could steal any gal from
you that you're sitting down talking to
right and that and that shouldn't be the
case right like you should have a leg up
by the time you're 23 right like you
should have a lot more opportunity and
and the starting point but I want you to
begin with is as soon as you're done
with this I want you to message your
friend and be like we're training
what's your schedule like when do you do
it when you get your supplements in
order how many hours a night do you
sleep
eight eight hours perfect make sure you
get plenty of sleep you get quality
sleep like it's deep sleep like you're
sleeping straight through the night you
don't wake up
sometimes for the most part yeah okay
good okay so so I mean you've got your
sleep down which is great because I mean
that's an area that people can can
struggle with but it's diet and exercise
pick up heavy [__] put it down move more
eat better you know make sure you're
getting in sufficient protein
and train training keep doing it until
you get your body weight up to Summer
where it's reasonable for your height
um
don't turn yourself into a bodybuilder
turn yourself into somebody that looks
like a professional swimmer you know
what swimmers look like you know we're
talking like Michael phelps's yeah yeah
that's what you need
all right that's good good guidance
that's all you need honestly like women
don't want like jacked up like Juiced up
guys they don't even want jacked up guys
because I mean you're too bulky and and
it sucks to live in that body anyway
because you can't walk around you don't
get shirts that fit you properly you
know your thighs are up together when
you walk you don't want that anyway it's
just aim for like a swimmer's build
which is for your height you're gonna
say 150 560 pounds
yeah I think I can attain that all right
so do that
um as far as the awkwardness
um I mean you know that you need to work
on that I'd keep doing the Toastmaster
stuff get into Social Circles man
um another thing that I would recommend
for you and you may not have the
interest in it
um but I would say get into some sort of
like something competitive something
that forces you to compete if you like
to compete in the intellectual World
join a chess club if you like to compete
in the Physical Realm do volleyball do
murder ball do ball hockey uh you know
um get into Combat Sports man I love
Combat Sports I can't recommend it
enough to people I really can't I mean
at the end of the day what would happen
if the [__] hit the fan for you
what do you mean the zombie apocalypse
comes a freaking meteorite you know
comes out of the sky and wipes out 35 of
the world's population you know like I'm
talking about the [__] hits the fan like
would you be able to survive
probably not
right so you'd be fodder right like you
would be one of the first people to go
down does that feel good to think about
life that way
no no I know I have a lot of work to do
as I said I mean I'm not like the
strongest guy do you know what the
concept of anti-fragility is
I can get gather okay well there's a
book called anti-fragile so let's so
just explain it to you I mean if you
want to dive through it dive through it
but I would definitely recommend
um you know consuming more audio books
you know if you have time I mean you can
do the audiobooks while you're at the
gym but the concept of anti-fragility is
when chaos comes into your life it
improves right like your life gets
better so if I were to take this uh Sam
Pellegrino uh bottle you just close the
top so it doesn't make anywhere but if I
were to take this bottle and I were to
put it in a cardboard box and ship it to
you
um I would have to write Fragile on it
because if that box was dropped by the
shipping company the glass would break
and the water would go everywhere and
you'd never get it
sorry
that's my ringtone
um so this would be an example of
something fragile something robust would
be like uh getting a bag of sand throw
you're putting in a box and shipping it
to you it's not going to get worse it's
not going to get better if somebody
drops it's just a bag of sand right
anti-fragile means that you become
better as chaos comes in your life
you see what I'm saying here so when
difficulty comes at you
do you get better as a result of that
difficulty can you get better as a
result of that chaos
because right now you as a man are
fragile
right like there's like there's probably
women out there that weigh 130 pounds I
could probably smoke you in a boxing
ring right
yeah yes you see what I'm saying right
like you know strengthening yourself up
and becoming more robust and less
fragile and as you become more robust
and you can lean into anti-fragile but
when chaos and [__] comes at you in your
life because I'll be honest with you man
like you got to be hard on yourself
because the world's indefinitely harder
on you like the world is a difficult
place it is ruthless and it doesn't give
a [__] about anything and you need to be
tough on yourself right
yeah I know you see what I'm saying so
you need to hold yourself to standards
right like you got to get out of the
shower and look at yourself in the
mirror and just say what the [__] is
this right like would you bang you
yeah
you might as a chick
um not bad looking I mean yeah but but
you're small though right at 110 pounds
like you're like your
um fragile right like you're not a a
beast I I I understand that that's what
I'm saying like a woman given the choice
between somebody lean and fragile like
that is going to pick the guy built like
a swimmer
probably right so if you want to
eliminate the competition or if you want
to even compete
if you want to compete on a sexual
Marketplace against other guys like
you're up against guys that are
physically fit that have a V taper broad
shoulders narrow ways you know like
those kind of guys and you're not going
to be able to get a woman's attention
having that fragile sort of appearance
in the world you know carrying yourself
that way so this is like one of the most
fundamental things that you know that
you got to start with and starting lean
my friend you know like I said earlier
starting lean is way better than
starting heavy I mean if you're 300
pounds I'll be like
you got even more work to do bro
but at 110 at least you have only up to
go
yeah that makes sense okay
um
don't stop dating don't stop dating you
know get out there talk to gals you're
gonna you're gonna struggle still
but you know it's you know the whole
notion of you're not going to score a
goal if you don't get on the ice I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out